in this video i'm gonna be breaking down
the sixth episode of attack on titan
season four
in which the warhammer titans identity
was finally revealed surprising everyone
who hadn't already been spoiled by the
youtube comments section
this video will explain everything that
i thought was interesting about the
episode
including the epic return of the scouts
the unique abilities of the warhammer
titan
and the real reason why mikasa's hair is
so short now
before we begin thank you guys for your
response to my review of episode 5 last
week
as we managed to get trending on youtube
which was just totally insane
as usual let me know your thoughts on
the new episode down below and be sure
to subscribe for more breakdowns like
this
okay so episode 6 was called the
warhammer titan and it joins an
exclusive club of only three other
episodes to be named after a titan
shifter
following on from his grand appearance
during the declaration of war aaron
continues the carnage
by eating the body of woolly tiber which
was his attempt to steal the warhammer
titan
as the head of the tiber family willie
was assumed by aaron to be the possessor
of the warhammer
but we soon find out that it was a
different member of his family that
appeared during the opening scene of
this episode
the conversation between willy and
magath in the opening scene happened
prior to the big speech
and as i mentioned in my review last
week both of these men suspected that
there would be an attack from paradise
one of the consequences was that willie
decided to group mali's military
generals close together
during this performance and aaron plays
right into his hands
by wiping them all out completely with
the military leaders now dead
this action made commander mcgath the
highest ranking officer alive
so once this is all over mcgath can
rebuild the military leadership from
scratch
which is exactly what really wanted to
happen by this early point in the
episode aaron's body count is
comfortably in the hundreds
as he's destroyed an apartment building
full of aldeans wiped out the military
leaders
killed government officials from other
countries around the world
and caused a ton of rubble to crush
innocent civilians
zafia was one of the people killed by
the falling rubble and she was a warrior
candidate who was competing to inherit
the armored titan
we didn't really get to know her that
well other than gabby saying she was
weird
but still it's a sad situation despite
sofia's death being instant
voodoo couldn't process the fact that
she was dead and urges gabby and colt to
help him
save her but in the process udo himself
is crushed by a stampede of people
who are trying to escape erin's rampage
udo's death was confirmed later in the
episode when cult attempted to get him
treated
which means that now currently three out
of the five warrior candidates
are either missing in falco's case or
confirmed dead
gabby and colt are the only ones we know
are okay i mean mentally they might not
be okay but you know what i mean
as the destruction continues the true
identity of the wahama titan is revealed
and it was the youngest sister of woolly
tiber
while we don't know her name she was in
the background when the tigers first
paid commander mcgath a visit
and she can also be seen at the
beginning of this episode as she just
stands there by the door
the warhammer being this unremarkable
background character was a
really smart move because anyone looking
to steal the power
would never really suspect her as the
warhammer begins to manifest
we get a look at the first of its unique
abilities which is seen when it
manifests from the ground upwards
every other shifter in the series always
manifests from the nape area
because that's where the holder of the
shifter is located but the warhammer
breaks this tradition
as the user can choose to encase
themselves in a crystal instead
this crystal is similar to the one that
annie created and there is a cable
connecting the crystal
to the warhammer titan this means that
willy type of sister can remotely
operate it
and the reason it manifested from the
bottom upwards is because the cable was
attached to its feet
in this moment eren's brutality towards
this titan was absolutely hilarious
as he wouldn't even let it fully
materialize before he just started
beating the crap out of it
as he hardens his face and continues the
onslaught you'll notice that commander
mcgath made a point
to be the first one to shoot against
eren this shot obviously did nothing
against a titan
but mcgath's behavior can be explained
when we look back a couple of episodes
ago
when william the commander first met
willie stated that marley was in need of
another hero like hellos
and i'll explain why mcgath is trying to
fulfill that role mali's current
position in the world is that they are
despised by other countries for their
constant use of the titans in war
and they are beginning to become weak as
other nations develop better weapons
the reason why he said they need another
hero is because if a malian is able to
stop aaron and save the world
then the world's negative feelings
towards mali can mostly be forgiven
willie fulfilled his part of the deal by
reminding the world of the threat of the
founding titan
and now magath must do his bit by being
the heroic marlian that was the first
person
to fight back against this threat of
course both magath and helos would
almost be like fake heroes who didn't
really do much in reality
but it's not about what they actually
did it's more about the story that can
be told to the world
that's why mcgath wants everyone to
remember that he had the first shot
because as the new general of mali's
military he can be the hero
with that said the warhammer titan
begins to fight back by generating a
spiky pillar
to pierce through the attack titan
leaving aaron hanging quite high up in
the air
the warhammer's signature ability
enables it to use a special type of
titan hardening with which it can create
structures that shoot out of the ground
like this
or even weapons that manifest inside its
hands whilst aaron is suspended in the
air
willy's sister conjures up that iconic
warhammer and attempts to decapitate the
attack titan
but luckily our boy escapes by
destroying a section of the pillar with
his own hardened fists
if i'm being honest about the animation
i'd be lying if i said the warhammer
titan didn't look a bit clunky
the most obvious example of this
clunkiness was later in the episode when
it was falling down
but even during this scene with the
warhammer it just didn't seem that great
to me
my personal take is that i preferred the
design and the style that we saw in the
trailer for season four
but let me know what you guys think
about this in the comment section down
below
anyway the anime gives us an update on
peak and porco who were trapped in this
hole by an unidentified malian soldier
in the last episode
they can hear the sounds of titans
fighting above them but they themselves
were unable to escape
because the place they're in is just way
too cramped to turn into a titan
luckily in the last episode pique was
suspicious of this malian soldier right
from the beginning
and so when she hugged this member of
the panzer unit she secretly told him to
follow them
in case something happened the panzer
team eventually shows up and frees the
two warriors
but the car titan can't join the battle
straight away because she needs to get
suited into her titan armor
on the other hand poco wanted to join
the fight immediately but is taken aback
when he notices people zipping above the
skies of liberio
thanks to the many letters that falco
sent aaron was able to contact the
scouts
who have now arrived to assist him now
if you guys cast your minds back to the
battle of force lava
you'll remember that these
armor-piercing rounds were used against
mali and were able to pierce the armored
titan
after winning the battle mali seized
those weapons and is now using them here
against aaron one of the officers urges
mcgath to kill the finding titan
to which he says no as he wants the
warhammer titan to eat it instead
in his words killing the founding titan
only postpones the problem
but you know what this is pretty much
the exact opposite of what he says in
the manga
as manga magath does want to kill the
founding titan because he believes the
age of the titans has come to an end
it's an interesting thing to change but
it doesn't really matter because wooly
type of sister
never had any intention of eating aaron
this time she successfully decapitates
him
made even more impressive by the fact
that he was using hardening to protect
himself
what happened was that the momentum of
the warhammer allowed it to break
through aaron's defenses
which i guess is why the warhammer is
the weapon of choice this attack
narrowly misses eren's real body
but the warhammer doesn't give up as she
prepares to deliver the finishing blow
from what we've seen in the series so
far most titans including titan shifters
are unable to speak but the warhammer is
one of the notable exceptions
and asks aaron if he has any last words
aaron replies by calling out to mikasa
who unleashes a barrage of thunderspears
right at the warhammer titan's name
in normal circumstances that might have
actually killed the titan shifter
but because of the remote control thing
willy's sister was able to survive the
encounter
the scouts then ambushed the malian
soldiers from behind and notice how
they're using modified versions of the
odm gear
the main difference between this and the
normal odm gear is that the gas
cylinders are on their back
and they use guns instead of swords
whereas kenny's crew had shotguns that
they needed to manually reload
these scouts have semi-automatic pistols
plus the space to equip
spears on top given that there's been a
three year time skip between the end of
season three and the beginning of this
season
obviously a lot of characters have
changed you know physically
and when it comes to mikasa her hair has
gotten significantly shorter
there is actually a funny reason for
this as in an interview two years ago
isayama revealed that mikasa had her
long hair in a ponytail
and accidentally cut the knot which
resulted in what you see before you
this accident where she cuts her
ponytail was never shown in the manga so
it's not actually a spoiler but it's
just a bit of trivia that i remember
reading
after blowing up the warhammer titan's
neck mika said tearfully asked erin to
come back home
and you can just tell by her expression
that she's fed up of erin cosplaying as
a hobo soldier in mali
she's also struggling to accept that
aaron is capable of doing what he did
as you know when you look at the
dialogue even she thinks that he doesn't
realize what he's done
as the scouts continue to wipe out mali
soldiers flock begins to go a little bit
overboard in his destruction
as he wants to maximize the damage to
mali in revenge for what they did to
paradise
this way of thinking is almost identical
to aaron who has destroyed everything he
could so far
and you know what at least they agree on
one thing because the last time we saw
those two interact
they did not see eye to eye jean however
doesn't really agree with maximizing
damage to mali in this way
as he has somewhat of a conscience and
he realizes that there are innocent
civilians who could be hurt
on the main battlefield the warhammer
titan pulls itself back together
and generates a functional crossbow made
from titan hardening which is something
you would have never thought possible
before seeing this titan
i explained this a bit more in a
different video but the warmer titans
hardening has a degree of flexibility
which enables it to create string to
make the crossbow work not to mention
whips that we briefly saw in this
episode
thankfully eren is not impaled by the
crossbow as mika said drags him out of
the way
and he tells her that his plan is to eat
the warhammer titan in order to do this
he needs to locate its real body which
requires that mikasa distracts it for a
bit
meanwhile gabi attempts to run back to
the battlefield to fight
after realizing that udo could not be
saved but in the process she is stopped
by the gatekeepers
these are the guys who watch the gate in
liberio and over the years they've
developed a friendly relationship
with both gabby and the warrior
candidates they try to warn her to stay
away
but are interrupted by the forces from
paradise who drop bombs on the nearby
malian soldiers
before sasha kills the gatekeepers with
a rifle she is a hunter at the end of
the day
gabi's life is spared because sasha
presumably doesn't want to kill a kid
and both her and connie begin to head
off as part of their plan
the parody soldiers begin to fix light
installations onto certain rooftops but
we'll talk about that more in the next
episode
when all is revealed gabby remains down
on the street
and in this moment you can't tell me
that she doesn't remind you of a young
vengeful eren
after the attack on the walls both aaron
and gabby saw people they loved
destroyed by the enemy at a young age
although in gaby's case she has an
advantage because she knows who the true
enemy is
and where to find them in erin's case he
just thought his enemy was the titans
but obviously as we know it was way
deeper than just that
on the battlefield mikasa was majorly
stressing out the warhammer titan
but this was good because it was giving
aaron enough time to work out its secret
he already knew that the user was not in
the titan's neck and he realizes that
the real warhammer titan
is located near the spot where it first
materialized the thick cable connecting
the crystal
to the titan they didn't try to hide it
or anything like that so aaron can see
this thing
and he knows where to go in his titan
form he grabs the crystal from
underground
and then proceeds to snap the cable in
half the warhammer titan can't function
unless that cable is connected
so it collapses into a lifeless husk
before aaron attempts to eat willy type
his sister
just before this levi makes his first
cameo appearance of the new season
standing on top of the structure that
the warhammer previously used to attack
eren
levi is the only scout who stuck with
his swords instead of bringing a firearm
and this turned out to be a genius
decision based on what happened next
earlier in the episode we saw how poco
was eager to join the fight
and as aaron is about to eat the wahima
titan he finally
arrives sneaking up behind the attack
titan and yeah i guess attempting to
steal the founding titan
the draw titan's mouth is incredibly
powerful so if he actually had time to
take a full bite
then there would be nothing eren could
do to stop it thankfully levi
was able to cut through the muscle of
the draw titan's mouth which prevented
poker from clamping down
what was funny was how terrified poco
was of levi once he realized that this
was the acumen
like judging by the way he was running
away you'd have thought he saw like
another titan shifter or something like
that
not a human being who just has two
swords as he tries to escape the area
the draw titan collapses to the ground
after being hit with a thunderspear
the episode ends on a bit of a
cliffhanger as the soldiers circle
around him in a very intimidating
fashion
and poco looks genuinely shaken in this
moment
just before we end the video i did
really like that opening scene
of how willy was interacting with his
kids i mean to be honest when we saw
them for the first time i didn't
actually think those were his kids
i don't know who i thought they were i
just assumed they were like other family
members but i know it is quite crazy to
see that and i i do like it when the
anime kind of expands
on uh on certain characters more than
what we saw in the manga
let me know what you guys thought about
episode six how would you rate it out of
10 compared to the other episodes
i would personally give it like i reckon
give it like a
7 out of 10 compared to the previous
episodes let me know what you guys think
in the comments down below
and as usual i'd appreciate if you
dropped a like if you like this video
and share it with anyone who you think
might enjoy it thanks for watching and
until the next one
peace out